hey it's your boy soldier boy man make
sure you check me out on the bootleg cab
podcast Soldier season out right now
bootle cap show we got a special guest
in here Soldier season is out
just tore down Las Vegas last weekend
by the way you just had a baby too right
congratulations thank you thank you yup
yup so is the season out right now man
Draco is here soldier boy is in the
building man yo man it's your boy so I'm
in the building man what's popping it's
good to see you man for sure man it's
good to be back you know what I'm saying
what's it like are you changing diapers
right now
oh you know a little a little something
like that you feeling me would you let
the mom handle the diaper changing a
little something like that a little
something like that yeah you ever had
your kid like accidentally put on you
while changing a diaper it's happened to
me so I gotta ask a little something
like that yeah it's rough uh the new
album's out though man Soldier season
how you feeling about it I feel good man
you know what I'm saying album out right
now man Soulja season he did what I'm
saying all streaming platforms I go get
it you know I just really had to lock in
like
you know I feel like it's the sound that
I want to present to the people you know
what I'm saying I've been locked in the
studio just cooking up cooking up
cooking up cooking up and then I finally
found the space well I'm like okay I'm
ready right now yeah like and you're
still independent right yeah and you're
doing what you want independent No No
Label you know saying I got my own
record lab with sodmg of course you know
what I'm saying shout out to
sodmg Legend hey rap I don't know what
he's doing right now but shout out to
him yeah not for sure man you know so so
you're signing artists too yeah
definitely sign an artist
um looking for new talent I always you
know shout out to be no hood trophy be
no flow Malcolm they doing their thing
right now we just you got a kid named
Ronnie on your tape too right get money
low running yeah you know I'm saying
free my boy yo yo hood fan yo yo go yeah
yo he'll be home soon you know what I'm
saying the whole Hood Fame movement you
feel me shout out my boy you know I do
feel like you were kind of like the
first rapper to embrace a lot of rappers
in the last like 10 to 15 years now for
sure like I feel like you kind of put
your arm around a lot of dudes before it
was cool to do so pause
um
was there who was the one like give me a
few names that like almost signed the
sodmg back back in the day or recently
that just it didn't end up working out
I don't know man this doesn't need to
hear no doubt man shout out to them
dudes man you know what I'm saying but
you know I just feel like now it's all
about learning I feel like I learned
going through working with them artists
you did what I'm saying it wasn't really
all about like signing them you know at
the time it was just really just you
know working you feeling like getting
new music you know and it would just me
not thinking about like you know the
business of the politics I just really
like okay I like this artist I want to
do a song with him let's work see what
we can do right yo
I think Daddy pulled up to take pics I'm
don't need my phone you want to grab her
I stopped
oh shout out to Soulja Boy for people
who don't know he's the only rapper I
think we've ever had on the podcast it
was early
I for sure thought we had the interview
scheduled for 2 30. I for sure thought
we would go see Soulja Boy until 3 15.
oh man you came early I got pulled up at
two bro damn I thought it was two I'm
here oh I love it no no no this is good
this is great I like that the schedule
wrong I thought that said two it said 2
30. I love it man yeah and I just been
doing I've been all over the place you
know what I'm saying how was um you know
because the lovers and friends look like
a crazy day man everybody was I mean I
really wish I could have made it out but
I had some family stuff I had to get to
but how crazy was uh that Festival
I mean outside you you killed it I saw
some footage you killing it it was
turned it was lit man you know what I'm
saying I can smoke again yeah I mean
you've been smoking in here since the
interview started so at what point in
time are we I just thought about it my
fault but now uh that [__] was lit man
you know what I'm saying it was a lot of
people out there I love Vegas you know
I'm saying I like the casinos I like
gambling I like I like Vegas I like
seeing the fans out there so did you
pass through and see our good Folks at
Jardine yeah you've been there before
yeah I always thought through there you
know what I'm saying they got they got
the best weed out there man I think you
were like a guest Bud tender or
something before at Hardy and I feel
like I saw you like guess butt tending
yeah I did like an event with them
promoting one of my singles and we was
out there and doing that if it was cool
you feel me yeah and uh in the pandemic
you obviously caught another hit with uh
to make a clap record no for sure for
sure man get Nikki on the remix I think
I don't think Nikki was on the remix
when you and I spoke last I think the
record was doing its thing but Nikki
hadn't hopped on it yet yeah
um how big of a deal was that for you I
mean look you're a legend but Nikki's a
legend too you know I mean how dope is
that to like get Nikki on a record like
that man I always just be trying to come
up with new new stuff for you know
people to gravitate towards like it
would be a lot of artists that you know
I'll be working with behind the scenes
and you know some stuff don't go through
and stuff like that but you know what
I'm saying that's what we're working on
now make sure all the all of the good
features Big features they go through
and stuff like that but be a lot of
behind the scenes stuff but Nikki she
been doing it for a long time and I've
seen her come a long way since the
beginning of her career and
you know she uh hopped on that
um she got a dunk beat and did it it'll
be piggy one of her most legendary
moments earlier in her career you know
what I'm saying so it's like I've been
rocking world since the start man and
I'm proud of her show she did that so
like it's almost crazy too because
there's there's probably like a small
because dunk is a classic but there's
definitely like a portion of the world
who heard that song first and then Ben
discovered oh this is a Soulja Boy song
that's such a like such a dope moment
because I feel like that's like a one of
those freestyles that
you know for talking about it 13 years
later it's legendary you know what I
mean not for sure for sure uh um what's
up with the what's up man what are you
in the NBA young boy hanging out I saw
you going in on the internet today
what's going on what's going on man it's
just um
she sent the little tweet out so I just
responded man it's all good I was like I
just he said this ain't a meet and greet
yeah I'm saying this ain't no man [__]
I come to business you know what I'm
saying let me agree but at the same time
though you know Soldier season now I'm
just so happy to fall on the same day so
it's gonna be some some competition you
did when I'm saying but at the end of
the day man shout out shout out young
would you ever do a record with uh young
boy
I would do a record with them uh yeah I
do a song on the main tripping yeah and
I like that yeah again I feel like he
puts out so many albums that he probably
puts out a lot of albums on the same day
as a lot of artists
because he drops every other week so he
had nothing doing him I announced an
album and then Dirk came and said he was
dropping on the same day then he came
well he said he was coming on drugs he
weren't really in it he filmed him he
just he just got in it you did what I'm
saying because he wouldn't drop on the
same day it's it's dirt
and to be fair what you said was was was
the truth because I just had this moment
go viral I don't know if you saw where I
said the little Dirk
who has tons of plaques is extremely
successful but I don't think he's had
like a he hasn't it's factual he hasn't
had a top 10 Billboard single oh yeah on
his own yet he's been on Drake songs
but and there was no like slight to him
but you're right yeah man ain't no disc
manifest when you got the fastest man
those guys don't gotta Crank that and
that's it's a fake I'm saying but at the
end of the day like man this is this
competition man y'all gonna get the
album man yeah those guys got other
records they got hellcats to trackhawks
yeah you know I'm saying but he moved it
but they back though so I ain't even
tripping do you think Dirk pushed the
album day back because of you
I don't know for sure why I saw you
thanked him or you shouted him out I
shot him out that's a real [__] [__]
like you know what I'm saying if you see
him on the internet tweaking obviously
it means something to me you've been so
[__] you know I don't know 100 the
reason why he did it but he did it you
feel what I'm saying I saw [__] I
respect that a lot man that's a real
[__] like if one of my partners was
dropping we dropped album on the same
thing he had a problem with it I pushed
my [__] back if I had if I had the power
to do it if it went too late you know
what I'm saying so what'd you think of
the new record did you listen to his new
record with J Cole I think it's yeah I
heard it it's different it sounds
different I think it's his best record
like in terms of like he might get a
Grammy you go get some radio success
like you know he's got some crazy joints
but I think that's a record that's like
I could be like oh this is a single
single you know it's different for
something for sure for sure
um tell me like man how do you go about
business ventures because I feel like
you're one of the more like
entrepreneurials just minded artists
we've had in the last 15 years I think
back to like yums and obviously you've
had shoes and you've you've had so many
things that we can point our finger to
and be like man Soulja Boy just you're a
hustler bro for real not for sure man
like uh that's how I've been since day
one like I always trying to get some
money man you know when it come to
businesses I just do stuff that I'm
interested in you know I'm saying like
video game console clothing fashion
um you know the blind I got the soldier
blunts with signature shout out to
Signature my man TR you got Soldier
Bloods yes Soldier blunt raps you know
I'm saying black cherry flavor you know
I'm saying signature smoke brand my boy
T.I he put that together you know I'm
saying shot big shout out to him
um I just I just check I gotta get a bag
kill we gotta Get This Money Man by any
means necessary you remember me so you
know but we're just doing we're doing
what we like though you feel me I rock
with the fashion Soulja Boy apparel I
we've spent all this money on Gucci we
spent all this money on Louis Vuitton
why we can't come out with our own
clothing line people support you feeling
I mean you had a very big clothing line
that's a fact and that's and that's what
it's all about I mean yeah I'm just
running rampant for a couple of years
yeah and it's like you like man I got I
got dreams too I got a vision too you
feel what I'm saying I'll be looking at
Gucci I'm looking at Louis how big it is
so I'm trying to be on that level you
feel me uh what have because I've last
time you were here we talked about the
video game console and I know you've had
some
you know a couple of complications with
rolling it out but I but you have been
pretty transparent with your fans on
what's going on you know with with the
video game console what is going on with
the video game console we just did a
deal with Walmart man shout out to
Walmart we in all Walmarts you know
saying y'all go walmart.com go order
today so I was a boy game trdr pocket
um we just added artificial intelligence
into AI you know what I'm saying so high
on the iPhone you can talk to Siri video
game console you could talk to it and
talk back to you you know what I'm
saying we'll talk back on your voice we
could we got that too you didn't because
that would be crazy so you know but um
it was a hard process you know but we
here now you feel me and I want to thank
Walmart for being the first big you know
store to support me you know I'm saying
and we got we about to go into like uh
four more stores in the next couple
months that's big man I'll be on lookout
for that so it's like people buy the
console it comes pre-loaded you can get
whatever you want on their games Spotify
Apple music you know I'm saying it's a
whole whole platform me whatever you
want to get yeah y'all go get that album
play the social season album off the
console you could listen to it on the
soldier what's the name of the video
game Soulja Boy game soldier boy you can
see you're fully vertical at this point
you know what I'm saying yeah
how do you think artificial intelligence
uh is gonna change the rap game because
you know you I'm sure you've seen a lot
of these crazy uh
likes fake songs from artists yeah I
mean I just feel like you know I don't
know we gotta we got it's still new so
we gotta wait and see like I want
somebody to take someone random like
Adele and make an AI version of Adele
doing crank that that's all right
let's do it someone's gonna do that out
there because they're gonna see this
yeah somebody's gonna like it's possibly
the possibilities is endless man you can
do so much stuff but it's at the end of
the day it could be a good thing it
could be a bad thing you just gotta wait
and see how do you think it could be bad
you know people use it in the wrong way
you know what I'm saying or you know do
you have a are you like pretty hip to
the uh like you know just the AI [__] in
general you have you have you [__]
around on chat gbt yet yeah I I I've
been I've been you know on through all
the AIS you dig what I'm saying chat GPT
and all that you know what did you what
did you converse with chat gbt about
because I actually know artists who have
asked
chat GPT what they should do for their
album rollout yeah and like it'll write
like a 10 paragraph like album roll out
now I know no it's funny like
the [__] that I I typed in a couple
things but the [__] that I typed in it
was like oh I can't help you with that
hi sir that's right
okay okay where's the G-spot just know
that they have no answer for me they
said I can't help you with this sir I
said now close the app out they said
this is this this is you know we can't
we can't help you with this do you have
a electric car yet like an EV Tesla or
anything I'm gonna come out with my own
car so how's your car really come on my
own car How's that gonna have like is
this already is this something that's
real or are you just saying it sometimes
I feel like you just be saying [__] I
mean just it is it this ain't this is
this idea that I have okay said that
right now okay it ain't that an official
but you want to do a soldier card hey
come on man every time I let your car I
was like come on man but I like to touch
a little got the big TV screen you have
a Tesla I got no Tesla man I like I
gotta I like like Hellcat it's like I
got the Hellcat like I want to go fast I
want to I want to hear it you know but I
like it though it looked good right and
you know stuff like that it was just
kind of slow but did you see the Tesla
slow oh it's slow which what
do you know that the test was the
fastest car that anybody can buy in the
United States then a Lamborghini yeah
it'll smoke the Tesla Model S plaid will
smoke we're not talking about Tesla
Model flat we just want the regular
Tesla I'm telling you they're smoking on
Lamborghini man what okay listen the
Tesla Model has plaid watch this 140
000 what's this not Model S play at all
Tesla models can smoke a Lamborghini
that's what you told me I would say half
of them okay cool fix it half a model X
and a Model S well not all uh come on
man you're not telling me I might roll
in the wrong Tesla though you know what
I'm saying it was DJ Vlad Tesla I don't
know that [__] was slow it might have
been the right time wait first of all
you're hanging out with vladica it was a
long time ago it was a long time ago I
was about to say people even had me in
the Tesla that [__] was slow as [__] I
was like what the [__] I gotta go for
Atlanta what was the car ride like with
you and DJ Vlad and a Tesla he's like
look Soldier the car could drive itself
oh I'm like man watch out with this [__]
when are you gonna make your triumphal
return to Vlad
I don't know you know I'm gonna pull up
on them are you guys good now hell no
I feel like it's it's like
it also could be very
um
I feel like he'd probably throw you a
bag every three weeks to do an interview
like he does with boozy he I don't want
his money man yeah everything ain't
about the money sometimes just like
respect principles [__] like yeah morals
you know what I'm saying I got three
Styles bro I can make money yeah I could
walk out of here and make however much
money I want right now you know I
appreciate that about it
talk to you like
like an artist
that's why I [__] with you bro not for
sure what would you do I did hear that
you recently okay because I don't think
people understand as an artist that you
do private gigs sometimes sometimes you
do stuff for like uh oh yeah that's the
fact uh maybe a bar mitzvah or you go
and do something for like a tech company
yeah I heard recently well maybe not too
recent
that you had like a crazy show you did
in San Francisco was it for a tech
company or was it like a it was
something I'd be doing it was like a
private event but you got bagged out how
often are you getting like the private
event bags that we don't even hear about
that'd be coming a lot you know I'm
saying I do a lot of regular shows I got
a tour coming up but then you're right I
do a lot of stuff that people can't even
get into and people don't even have you
ever been to Bar Mitzvah yeah what was
that like it was crazy it was like like
you said it was a bad they got money I'm
like y'all got money like that to be bad
for that like wow how many songs did you
have to do I was like two three that's
it yeah that's amazing yeah bar mitzvos
I'm the best them the biggest bags
I'm the biggest bags just go and do a
bar mitzvah clean up do two or three
songs eat the free food be on your way
okay 100 but y'all get the tickets I'm
going on tour though Soldier world uh in
August I'm doing soldier World in August
30 30 plus Days by 40 days okay um we're
going everywhere who you going out with
just I mean have you gotten this is my
first headline until you know saying my
first two I did it was me Chris Brown
Bow Wow second tour was this your first
headlining tour of your car myself or my
whole career wow because you go back and
look at all my tools you see me on tour
with people you see me with Wayne you
see me with gz you see me with bow wow
everybody I'm saying so now it's just me
I'm gonna bring some people out though
like I'm gonna bring some of my rap
homies out I don't know who but you know
it's gonna be every city might be
different it's gonna be different every
city that's crazy crazy world I never I
never if I could have never have guessed
that you never did a headlining tour my
whole career is my first one that's why
I'm excited I'm like I can't wait to hop
on that tour bus hop on the plane you
know I always wonder like if you were to
go to your house in my head
like do you have like a museum and and
let's say the museum door opens up and
in the museum is like the first rubber
band necklace displayed the Gucci
headbands on display I got the Gucci
headband the sunglasses you know it's
crazy they just came
I don't want to say like I don't know
what channel I don't know what TV show
it probably has an area I'm probably
supposed to say but they're gonna put it
like in the one you know I'm saying Hall
of Fame joints I gave them the glasses
you gave him the glass I gave him the
glasses so they putting them in there
but did I keep the Gucci head mouth
there I kept the Gucci head man that
[__] so dirty it looks God by
the end of the last interview you did in
it it's debit is dirty as [__] I got it
though isn't I got you can see it in it
I'm like nah let's just put that God
damn that was an error yeah it was I'm a
save I gotta say that that was a [__]
error the guy that she had been you can
never get rid of that you can't yeah no
that should go into like a Smithsonian
some of the most memeable moments of all
time were with that headband on Drake
it's not for real hey uh so I obviously
we all ended up here in uh you on what
you were you on down to two
yeah you were on down to two which uh by
the way I had to buy this [__] thing
to listen to that was hard I bought this
[__]
this stem player stand player
haven't used it since right two hundred
dollars
got me for sure
um and you were supposed to be on the
first donda you got taken off right yeah
yep yep was that something you sent into
Kanye or and what was what was because
you had like been kind of you were kind
of [__] on you a little bit when you
didn't make the album but then you ended
up making Donna too so what was the
makeup like because he hit you up like
hey man my bad bro uh this is wilding
out man you know how I get I just like
to speak my mind keep it real man like
you know what I'm saying you were
wilding out on Instagram today all the
time yeah I'm saying every day but you
know it's just that's just me you know
what I'm saying you know but you know I
just I just speak my mind and I feel
like he could have just you know left
kept my verse on the album you know man
you had to do all that and then the
verse he actually included doesn't even
come out on dsps it's on this [__]
stem player that nobody [__] uses you
know what I'm saying but it was cool to
go in redo the verse get it done you
know what I'm saying and everybody was
happy everybody was happy so have you
talked to yay recently is he good I
don't know if you if you guys chat ever
well last time I saw yeah yeah but you
know he got he got a lot going on you
know what I'm saying so it's kind of
like I'm assuming he's not doing many
bar mitzvahs anymore I don't know what
do you got going on you know what I'm
saying but like you know I just try to
like
when you see stuff like that just
support you know that's right because
like when everything cool and everything
all good it's cool you know we could
play around with control but we see
somebody going through serious stuff for
sure just pause everything like you just
send them love and support you know what
I'm saying yo what's good man we gotta
stop the interview to tell you about our
good Folks at my bookie that's right man
NBA season is uh winding down playoffs
are going down so many ways you can get
money you could bet on who you think is
going to win the finals you can get your
prop bets per game uh we are finally
down to the final eight right now uh my
son's ain't looking good at the time of
recording not looking good uh look go to
mybookie.ag right now sign up
I've been gambling on my Boogie for over
10 years so listen come and join me
let's get this money together
mybookie.ag when you use the promo code
bootleg when you sign up use that promo
code you're going to get that deposit
bonus that deposit bonus is craziest the
sign up bonus you get and uh not only
are basketball football which is
starting to creep up on us baseball's
back MLB baseball man all season long
you get this money plus they got the
online casino if you're into craps
Blackjack roulette [__] slot machines
whatever it is go to mybookie.ag right
now use that promo code bootleg and get
that free deposit bonus that's how we're
doing things all right also I want to
give a big shout out to the homies of
King Palm man these are our new sponsors
at King Palm now this is the thing about
these King Palms man these things right
here
ah natural natural leaves free of
tobacco and additives the only thing I
smoke out of and what's dope is they got
these other ones right these uh this is
one of their more popular items right
here
great flavor
these are the leaf rolls they hold a
gram each and they got the terpene fused
tips which means you squeeze and you pop
the tip while you're smoking your flour
and you get a little burst of flavor
these are the peach pineapples
um they got the energy drink flavor they
got blue blueberry watermelon all kinds
of [__] man
um so what's dope if you go to
kingpom.com and use the promo code
bootleg cab right now you're gonna get
half off half off half off kingpom.com
tobacco free
natural
raps all right and also don't forget if
you're in a I don't know wherever you're
at go to 7-Eleven they got them your
local smoke shop one of the most
successful uh businesses in the game
when it comes to the all-natural Leaf
the most successful no tobacco no
nicotine just natural Leafs to stuff
your flour in and in case you did not
know they also have
whatever size King Palm this is
this is a giant Leaf wrapped around yeah
wrapped around some premium can I buy
shout out to uh King pom go follow one
more time kingpong.com promo code
bootleg Kev say 50 off let's get back to
the interview I do feel like you've done
a really good job of mastering the
internet how much of the [__] you say
online are you like very self-aware on
it's gonna go viral
this is going to be a thing I mean I
don't know I just talked some stuff I
say people don't even post it you know
what I'm saying but most of the stuff I
say they post your family so I just try
to be like just be my be yourself you
know sound like man let me be myself
keep it real and that's what's going
what's the last thing that you were the
first rapper to do I just did some first
rapper [__] the other day
what was that first rapper [__] I did we
was something where I was the first
rapper to do uh damn I just did some
first rapper [__] the other day I ain't
gonna come I forgot you should do a
first rapper book like each page is like
Soulja Boy was the first rapper too yeah
do this what I just did I was somewhere
they said you the first rapper dude it
was real too I forgot I'm gonna remember
I forgot if they yeah yeah it was like
last week it was last week yeah like you
gotta stop smoking so much weed if you
can't remember you feel me it was
something it was yesterday I don't know
what happened [__] I prefer a rapper to
do something
yeah I forgot uh so when's the tour
start August August man you know saying
yeah come out check out we're gonna be
La Cali we're gonna be all over this
line are you going over here overseas
later you know what I'm saying overseas
uh this whole run is us run I'm August
September what uh is your favorite City
to perform in that isn't in the U.S so
far because you've obviously you've done
some wild like random places I gotta
pick one I can say something yeah do a
couple sure Dubai for show like Dubai
would be lit can't take the weed there
though but you don't need it like Dubai
so lit you're not even thinking about
the weed like they having Lamborghini
you've been in Dubai of course not they
uh what no I've not been to Dubai I'd
like to go you gotta go bro you got the
passport don't it yeah of course like
the next time I do a show and see hey
for a rapper to take before I rap [__]
again for a rapper to take care of the
[__] Dubai y'all [__] ain't
took care of Dubai yet what the [__]
y'all [__] tripping okay how long you
been doing this [__] like 20 years damn
yeah almost 15 15 16. that's long enough
they got me [__] up they got us [__]
up they got you [__] up what you mean
Cam ain't been to buy it and you gotta
passport stuff out there and say soldier
I ain't got my passport no I got my
passport I'm a girl got your pass what's
that we going to Dubai y'all [__]
tripping so you love Dubai where else
okay boom Paris Paris is great I've been
there Eiffel Tower [__] Brazil I'm
saying Germany have you been to
Amsterdam Amsterdam see before weed was
legal in America we was at the coffee
shops no you know about the coffee shop
yeah and the coffee shop is getting hot
they having so much weed you're going to
Coffee Shop these people put weed in
your coffee right you can drink the weed
with coffee they having all type of
Trades you pulling them out they're
having all flavor in Amsterdam in
Amsterdam like it's the trap house but
it's so cold it's cold but I love it
though did you uh partake in the red
light area of districts I'm I may have I
may have not of sorts
we may have may have uh experienced
something of the sort I heard like if
you walk through there's like walk
through that's all you got is that's
what we call it there's like a section
the walk through if you need a Latin
girl this is where they are there's the
and then there's the the walkthrough
yeah if I'm not mistaken
they be in the windows
they in the Windows like a [__]
mannequin on this play would you say
that uh as a grown-up you've you've
you've never mind I'm gonna ask a
question exactly I'm pretty sure yeah
yeah I don't wanna let's go okay I don't
want to [__] up either of our situations
come on
um beside okay so I know that now that
you're independent you can kind of drop
and work when you want how much music
you're trying to put out the rest of
year
oh man
I definitely want to do one more project
like I always uh drop on my birthday you
know I'm saying at least once a year
July in July do a project a year uh so
right now
to be honest um how I'm feeling on this
album I just want to chill I want to
promote this album and Just Vibe and
just do my thing but uh we'll see
hopefully you know maybe an album come
in July if not we'll probably get one
off like at the end of the year right
I'm saying towards winter time we'll see
how this album play out are you are you
still like uh like hopping online and
gaming a lot yeah twitch.tv I just got
unbanned they had me banned on there I
was banned they banned everybody on
Twitch for a year though what'd you do I
can't I can't say what I did but you
know I'm back though you know what I'm
saying you know what I'm saying they
just banned the Kaiser not dude yeah
he's like the biggest guy on I'm like
why would you ban your biggest Creator
and he's like a nice dude he ain't doing
nothing crazy yeah so I mean I just feel
like you know they got their policies
and stuff like that it'd be and they'd
be [__] creators I heard the split
that they be paying their twitch is
[__] up yeah but you know it's it's a
platform and you know it is it's good to
be back on that but yeah I'll be going
crazy man y'all GTA GTA we got RP got my
own server so you have your own server
so you're like full uh role play mode on
there I'm saying lit what happens if
someone breaks character on the mic
if it's too bad like if it's if they go
too far out of it you can get banned
from the server just kick them out I'm
saying so it's like we're about to go
rob somebody and they're like hey bro my
mom's tripping real quick hold on
I just want to make sure you know
because I know that t Grizzly should be
taking that [__] serious
shout out to see Grizzy he got his own
server to be going crazy yeah yeah it's
it's kind of he's making like six
figures a month just playing uh video
games yeah yeah have you gotten to that
point yet are you yeah man consistently
see I was at that point and then I got
banned so now you know I'm back now you
know what I'm saying so they were
[__] with you have you uh dabbled in
any mushrooms yet have you done shrooms
I got a funny mushroom story bro hell
yeah I took mushroom before bro oh my
God I ain't doing that [__] I might do a
little bit we'll do some right now not
right now all right well I got them if
you want one time I locked myself in the
in the closet in Las Vegas was in a
penthouse suite I'm in the closet locked
myself in the cloud and I'm looking up
at the ceiling and it's like a
see-through ceiling and I'm looking
through the [__] just tweaking to the
morning to the sunrise
yeah that was the first year second time
I did that [__] I was got down I just
passed out yeah it's one of the other
what the [__] I ain't doing this [__] no
more if you trip super hard dude it's
hard to go to sleep because you start
overthinking about everything dissecting
your whole life
I just laid in the bed and just wanted
to go to sleep I want that [__] to go
away
did you did you find a therapeutic were
you like overthinking [__] did you start
crying
I just felt like I was in a [__] like
like that have you ever had sex on
mushrooms
yes how was that Lit yeah
it's not bad you know what I'm saying
hmm
what's the best drug to have sex on do
you think
uh uh probably like percocet or
something like that I've never done a
Percocet perk I'm scared of that
especially with the fetty out now what
Percocet you might get a percocet and
end up [__] out of here bruh it's
serious though in the streets right now
kids don't do drugs it's bad yeah and
then they say uh I mean I've never done
ecstasy either I heard ecstasy is great
but I've just never done it uh you have
been Molly hmm I've only smoked weed in
eight shrooms
in there I think a little bit I think
it's the same thing MDMA right yeah that
was Trinidad James was that way he came
to my partner mommy I'm sweating
everybody popping mollies and [__]
Trinidad James did have the Molly wave
it's all good those are your soldier
wraps that's not a backwood
um how's your relationship these days
with Chief Keef That's my boy man I was
just with him the other day man that's
my boy man he became a long way to us
another person I'm proud of you family
seeing him come a long way to Come From
The Trenches Chiraq from nothing to you
family doing his thing I feel like you
guys used to be together so much and
um for sure you know you were kind of
like
a child star before him so I'm sure he
learned a lot of the things like to do
and not to do from you you know because
he was kind of like that generation
right after you yeah now for sure that's
my boy man like we just be kicking it
man you know what I'm saying like you
know we just be kicking and cooling you
know just talking about [__] smoking and
just gonna be on [__] what are some of
the like if you had to give let's say
there's an up and coming artist who's
steaming hot right now pause and they're
like maybe they got a couple of you know
viral records and they just moved to LA
I remember back in the day when you
would move to LA you know what I mean
like what would be some advice you would
give
some of these artists who are are
finally moving to LA and they're like
the music [__] starting to take off some
of the mistakes maybe you made that that
you know you can you know point out not
to do man
I just say come have fun man you know
what I'm saying like you know it's only
it's it's a once in a lifetime
opportunity you know what I'm saying
coming to La especially if you're
getting a record deal like if you're
coming and you sign like you know just
put out the best music you could put
make the best album you can make
um just have fun like it ain't really
too much like mistakes or nothing bad or
nothing like unless you just like doing
some crazy [__] like you know what I'm
saying but you know enjoy the moment
you're gonna meet a lot of people you're
going you know what I'm saying
you [__] I love it I love the other [__]
watch like when you first moved out here
there was like like you was like you
know you was like in the hood and [__] I
remember there's that virus oh like they
talking about that like going to the
hood and [__] like that like I mean I
mean you were in La Affiliated banging
and [__] I'm like soldier boy I met him
and he was a kid
remember what's
up that's it's La there's La for you you
know is that something that kind of has
to happen yeah yeah like you come to La
like you know what I'm saying like
it's just the fact that I live here and
I've been here for a long time right
like when I was in Atlanta and I was
coming back and forth from L.A to
Atlanta and I was mostly in Atlanta it
wasn't like that but coming in a lab in
it I've been living in L.A for like [__]
a long ass time now it's just last
[__] like it's like a decade yeah
yeah I'm saying so it's like you know
it's his out here so there you want to
go to the hood you gotta you gotta check
in right
um for you man like uh you obviously
have always had an ear for talent before
it pops right like who are you just a
fan of right now
that you're just like yo from Far like
maybe not even necessarily someone you
got a relationship with I'm a fan of
right now you mean like an artist yeah
just an artist yeah yeah overcoming on
just like regular artists anybody
damn oh I'm a fan of right now
uh
damn who really rapping like that right
now oh I'm just draw we'll be driving
I'll be listening to myself man like let
me see who I'm trying to think of oh
come on I like ice spice I ain't gonna
care I spices I like ice but that's
funny I could see a girl like he picked
a girl but [__] she knew though she
popping I like what she doing she got
some records oh gang like I found about
her like before like like before she got
popping off and [__] like that I was
talking to her and she her [__] just
took off so I'm like damn like you feel
me I like seeing like [__] like that
like [__] just be like you know
what I'm saying under the radar and then
just take off you feel me I like saying
[__] like that would you work with ice
spice yeah yeah
send the DM try to make it happen we all
right it's awesome we be talking I'll be
talking to her shout out to ice but she
cool
she's on fire I think she's the most
streamed artist like the last month or
so or something it's kind of crazy yeah
I mean I like I like what she doing for
sure uh
uh what about the last what's the last
album that you love that dropped
besides Soldier season which is out now
by the way it has album
um
that I like that drop probably was like
probably was like it's a couple of them
probably was like uh Drake and 21 Savage
[__] great album and then um
I like that single he dropped too that
searching search engine whatever search
and rescue that [__] hard as [__] Yadi
Yadi do [__] hard what's that new yachty
single strike strike yeah yeah have you
did you listen to yachty's rock album
did you listen to that I mean that's the
album you listen to you eat shrooms and
listen to that [__] I mean I ain't
really get to tap all the way into it I
heard like some of it I just feel like
he just being different and that's
that's that's what keep the culture
going forward right [__] always try
putting it inside a box you know what
I'm saying so will we ever get the I
mean I might be it might already be up
but the the Drake We Made It freestyle
will that ever make it to dsps
um [__] yeah yeah eventually
such like a legendary record I just I'm
surprised like I have to go on YouTube
to listen to it or depth.com YouTube
SoundCloud I forgot what happened with
that record man we supposed to shot a
video all type of [__] but you guys
shout out to Drake though yeah you guys
are good yeah he doing his thing man I'm
doing my thing and you know that's
another [__] I'm proud of too he came a
long way too that's funny I don't watch
a lot of careers come a long way bro
came a long way he does also say a lot
that you've figured out a way to be
relevant no matter what in the last
since wait you came out in 07 yeah so
like since 2007 we're talking about 16
years yeah that was the whole that was
the whole idea though from the start
kill you've been asked you've been
famous as long as you've like because if
you think about it you became famous
when you were 16 or 15. yeah 16. so
you've been famous now as long as you
were alive
before you were famous
fifty percent of your life you've been
living
both sides you know what I'm saying but
I just feel like I always wanted that
longevity you know what I'm saying you
know when I first came out that's gonna
be one hit wonder and then I had to come
with another hit then I had to come with
another hit me through the phone it's
like your biggest record on Spotify too
yeah yeah so but longevity that's the
key that's the key
[Applause]
yeah I was just because I was listening
to your new album and now I just I was
like man let me look at this [__]
because I'd be forgetting how many
records you got
I'm like Jesus Christ I've just I saw a
bird walk I was like I wonder what would
happen if birdwalk came out when Tick
Tock was popping oh damn I wonder would
have been like a tick tock would Crank
that would came oh my God it's [__]
insane you still got [__] you got 40
year olds cranking that you know
weddings and stuff oh for sure every
wedding is playing Crank that I don't
care how white and old or random it is
crank that's getting played there's like
a few hip-hop songs that get played in
every way Flo Rida's low with T-Pain
Crank that those are the only two I got
maybe some sort of Nelly ride with me or
something
nah it's good man like that love is
crazy like that support that that just
to see people still doing that for that
record that was a crazy record okay you
have because I feel like you've lived
the type of life that eventually will
get made into a Netflix series
or like uh
AMC show or something or FX who would
you have play you
and you's not an option
um right now yeah I mean yeah I mean I
don't know if you you can't predict
future actors yeah right now um
like Michael B Jordan or something like
that Michael B Jordan a soldier boy you
know I don't know that he read this [__]
who wants to lose so he's kind of yoke
your skinny guy I know that's a fact so
he's saying like who that's what I'm
saying we're actually there's not many
actors out there that really just look
like me Jordan a soldier boy would be
pretty wild who really look like me like
that that's kind of who could pull it
off like I would have to play myself you
would have to play yourself I gotta be
me nobody can't be Draco
okay would the the your famous Vlad
story
is that going to be in the show hell
yeah but it ain't gonna be no story it's
gonna be the real [__] you know what I'm
saying
it is summertime if you're dealing with
elect erectile dysfunction Ed if you
will maybe you got stress at work
maybe you're tired of looking at the
same chick
maybe you just need a little pep in your
step
um you need to get on that blue too man
you don't need to do anything but it'd
be nice to have the option to so go to
bluetooth.com right now
use the promo code bootleg and get the
first month supply of Bluetooth for free
what is Bluetooth
well Bluetooth is a chewable gets
delivered to your door in a discreet
package no doctor's appointments no
doctor's visits and uh it has the same
active ingredient as Viagra
and Cialis
so we're talking about getting your dick
hard here in case that went over your
head you know it won't go over your head
once you take it I promise you that uh
Bluetooth also is uh incredible because
not only does it come in the blue
chewable flavor with the same active
ingredient as vibrancy house but it also
has a mint chewable flavor which is the
same active ingredient as Levitra right
all this if you're questioning I don't
know I don't want to spend no money on
does this [__] work look yes it works
and you don't have to spend money if you
use the promo code bootleg at
bluetooth.com because it's going to get
delivered right to your house they're
going to give you a month's supply for
free you just got to pay five dollars
shipping that's it the bluetooth's come
into your house no awkward doctor's
appointments no awkward doctors visits
it's all online
bluetooth.com Thank Me Later what's up
guys hey um if you are watching this and
it's April 20th 4 20
I'm going to be hanging out at hardean
today
that's right put the flyer up The Rock
I'll be at hardeen um hanging out all
day today
um the craziest most just luxurious
illest dispensary in the world located
right in Las Vegas Nevada now Hardy in
Las Vegas they are our family they'd
sponsor the podcast I love those guys
dearly and when I say that it is the
best place I've ever walked into to buy
premium cannabis I'm not lying best
customer service
best bud tenders best bud
to put in your King Palm
and uh just overall man just a great
experience um so uh what y'all need to
do is go follow them online hardean
underscore Las Vegas follow them on the
gram
we got a lot of dope stuff in the works
they actually just opened a a fire
podcast studio so we're gonna be doing a
lot of content in Vegas
live from Hardin they also just dropped
a [__] tennis shoe with Fila they got
dope flag gear
um man premium cannabis the best
selection
culture
sniff you walk in that man listen they
got I'm not even lying to y'all Harding
has their own signature scent and it
smells good I keep a bottle of it in my
car literally maybe twice a day I spray
that get that hard eating whiff smells
amazing so look make sure you go to
hardine uh if you're in Vegas get in
that Uber get in that cab as soon as you
touch down say take me to hardine the
taxi drivers the Ubi drivers they know
exactly where it is because it's the
hottest spot in Vegas they go take you
straight there you're gonna tell them I
sent you they're going to get you
situated real nicely all right Harding
underscore Las Vegas go show them some
love go to hardinglasvegas.com gotta
give a shout out to our oh geez my dogs
had Odd Socks baby they've been [__]
with us from day one
um and they've been dropping so many
crazy dope new like socks you know first
of all can we talk about Beavis and
Butthead they just dropped the Beavis
and Butt-head socks and draws let's take
a check just a nice little peek at the
Beavis and Butthead oh
come on man
they also just dropped Coca-Cola we got
Scarface we got Reese's we got the big
[__] Lebowski so many dope socks the
most comfortable socks in the world the
most comfortable underwear in the world
and check this out right now you can get
20 off that's 20 off at checkout
at oddsoxofficial.com using the promo
code bootleg so go right now
otsoxofficial.com my first uh suggestion
would be get you a pair or a pack of the
Odd Socks Basics the black and the
whites those are my go-to's and then you
gotta [__] with some of these Big
Lebowski socks and they just got
Coca-Cola
they got the Scarface boys like what are
we talking about man what are you
waiting on they are the most comfortable
socks in the world
um so if you're not wearing Odd Socks
you're just cheating yourself you know
what I mean you're really cheating
yourself
they got [__] South Park
come on bro what are we talking about
go to oddsocksofficial.com right now use
the promo code bootleg say 20 off at
checkout on the most comfortable socks
in the world or don't and keep torturing
yourself with those shitty socks you're
wearing right now
be a damn shame anyway let's get back to
the interview
the you've seen the like reenactment
cartoons of you that [__] was hard it's
great that should be a real cartoon
series zero percent of that story was
capped that was all actual factual
that's what's going on man but I can't
really speak too much that [__] that
with so many Twisted terms it did I
don't even I can't even yo say I said
what I said man that's a quiet yes
you know what I'm saying like you do
possess some of the best internet
moments of all time so
you have like a [__] you're like the
internet moment God it's like you and
Kevin Gates right now
when Kevin Gates said and he puts his
hand car battery and it just
it just I was like nah
what are we talking about right now like
what are we doing bruh anyway
um all right so you got the game console
at walmart.com the walmart.com man y'all
go order y'all one today man the new
album new album so just season out right
now tour in August Soldier World Tour in
August September going crazy you have
closeout Soulja boyapparel.com go order
you some hoodies you know what I'm
saying all my designers out there yeah
Soulja Boy apparel you're wearing nah
this ain't Soulja Boy apparel right here
hang on okay so I gotta I got a serious
question to ask you I gotta be honest
with you let me give you some business
advice from a guy who
you know I've seen a lot of people say
wear the clothing line no no no just
hip-hop clothing lines I've seen them
all come and go usually oh yeah usually
the ones that have the rapper's name in
the title of the clothing line fail
miserably yeah think about it Snoop Dogg
clothing ate [__] Outcast clothing what
about what about Sean John
that's it that wasn't called Puff Daddy
clothing though Sean John it was called
Sean John it wasn't called Puff Daddy
clothing but he changed that Diddy puffy
P we didn't know what his name was at
the point nobody's wearing that [__] if
it's called did he close
but what did a Rebrand Soldier Boy
apparel is not it whatever they say
bootleg Kev podcast is not it well I'm
not putting out [__] clothes but you
put out a podcast and they got your name
in it it's the same thing I'm gonna be
honest it's the same thing
right now people are gonna wear my
[__] name I wouldn't I would never
ask somebody to wear my [__] name on
their [__] but why would you ask them to
listen to your podcast with your name
it's different how because who says it's
different you're not even wearing your
[__] it's sold out
sold out baby are you sure before I got
up here it sold out it's missing oh the
last show I can't I had to take the
hoodies off they was taking the hoodies
off of me I'm about to Google this [__]
right now
I'm gonna review your uh your your
clothes with you right yes
36 year old woman my man got a podcast
named the bootleg KF podcast and coming
at me cause I got Soulja Boy up here I'm
just trying to help you out I'm trying
to help you up bootleg Kev okay okay I'm
okay okay
let's get our name out there what you
want me to call it Soldier
boyapparel.com I'm on the website use
the cold Soldier for 10 off your order
yes we doing night we them hoodies is
flying right now I can see everyone we
went flying Soldier season sold it on
flying they're dripping let me can I do
okay people are buying slides with your
cartoon face on them yes you want to see
the back end I gotta show you the
statistics shout out if they're gonna
buy my album why when they buy my
clothes
if they gonna follow me why won't they
follow something with my name in it so
like okay this hoodie right it just says
Soulja Boy apparel that's fire it's not
what now you hating I'm not yeah it's
cool this is cool it's like a cartoon
version of you but you mean cool that's
fire too how many of this sweater did
you sell
a lot of this purple bro I have 11
million followers on Facebook seven
million followers on this people in
Bangladesh buying this [__] all over the
world I have 11 million followers on
Facebook seven I like the shorts those
shorts are fire fires seven million on
Instagram five million on Twitter you
don't think off of one post I'm not
doing how many sales I'm doing off of
one post okay I got it out Kev people
are buying this shirt right here yes
people buy people buy what go yard
it's the same style it's the same not me
I can't do my not you but people are
what's your favorite uh designer brand
besides Soulja Boy apparel
um like are you like a Louie guy I mean
you have a Gucci tattoo on your forehead
so never mind that answered that right
it's Gucci you have them tattooed on
your face
no that's okay you love Gucci uh I love
Gucci can you be honest with me at any
point in time in your adult life have
you regretted the Gucci forehead tattoo
yes yeah
what the [__] hell yeah I was like God
damn I woke up like oh [__] what was the
day like when you got that because it's
not even a good tattoo it's kind of
fading you could tell like you might
have because I tried to get it removed I
went like two or three times at her time
now you can't really feel it the zap
yeah you can't really feel it you know
what I'm saying so what was the night
like that when you got that tattoo like
what was going through your head at the
time I was just lit you were [__] up
and I was just like Gucci I was addicted
to tattoos you know what I'm saying like
when I got my first tattoo
first tattoo was this tattoo Mr cartoon
shout out to Mr cartoon legend that 50
Cent back there of course he did a lot
of tests so he did my first tattoo after
I got that tattoo I was like
I just couldn't stop you know what I'm
saying so I didn't have no more space on
my body and my whole chest everything
got covered up so I started going to the
neck got from the neck start going to
the face you feel me so at the right
side the right side was going the left
side I was going so I could start going
through the middle then once I got to
the middle I was like I got stuck you're
like I love Gucci so much I spent like a
lot of money on Gucci like I'm gonna get
it tatted like I had to yeah you had to
I had to what happened though like why'd
you have to did they like have some sort
of like embarrassing video of you or
something no I spent too much money like
I'm like
so because you I spent too much money
with the LA water department but I'm not
getting ladwp on my phone so you being
funny I'm being serious like how much
how much money have you spent on Gucci
over a million I mean I think I figured
that much of a million so you know what
I'm saying I'm like yeah I got like is
this a symbolism same thing with the
Bentley logo I got the Benny logo the
greens that's 250 000. I'm like yo if
I'm putting my much money in something
this [__] gotta be for me for life like
I came for the churches I came for
nothing I think you should get the
soldier boy apparel tattoo right over
that
oh my God now you're being funny come on
you own the brand well not right there
though in another location somewhere you
know I'm saying that look you know what
I'm saying or at least that's right
because no matter what while you're
promoting Soulja Boy apparel people are
watching this and you're also indirectly
promoting Gucci there's nothing wrong
with that okay I just wanted you're
promoting the competition you indirectly
Pro promoting a lot of [__] in the in
this background Kev there's nothing
wrong with are you do you got to deal
with WWE are you a wrestler you are a
cross-promoting WWE on your part hey
when are you gonna start right by the
way it's not a big deal when are you
gonna start wrestling
this seemed like it was a thing this was
to seemed like a thing that might have
happened you was popping off on some of
these wrestlers online
I forgot who you were going at it with
too I mean me too I forgot I don't even
know these people but that was coming at
me but shout out to Stone Cold I just
made Stone Cold he was a legend nice guy
I used to watch me growing up I was one
stone cold to Stun Me pause like I'd be
like bro hit me with the stunner bro
look he's behind you on the poster no he
was Legend he a legend for show I'd be
like bro hit me with the stunner bro let
me [__] slam the beers and then Stun
Me for Tick-Tock he had a legend for
some shout out to Stone Cold Steve
Austin will you have you did you see
Snoop wrestling yeah ceasefire and Snoop
was out there like you know he's done
the aw thing I mean I'm not against it
you know what I'm saying
I'd rather box though like I'm sorry
about the hop in the Box you do like
some Floyd Mayweather celebrity boxing
yeah why did you and uh Chris Brown ever
fight I don't know it seemed like that
was really close to happening at a
certain point in time and I don't know
but [__] we need to promote more
positivity anyway that's a good thing we
ain't fighting I mean I'm saying that
was my brother you know I'm saying like
at the point of time you know I'm saying
I always like Chris Brown music I always
rock with him so I felt like that whole
[__] was just some [__] anyway you
know what I'm saying right I just seen
him plenty times since then would you um
but would you do like you know we see a
lot of artists now getting paid like
High purse money to actually go do a
real yeah I'm knocking [__] out give me
the bag I'm in there so you're like you
know participate maybe like uh you know
blue faces fighting ddg's fighting
there's a lot of rappers who are not I'm
not talking about fighting on some
negative [__] they're boxing getting
paid that's hard would you fight
blueface man I'll fight anybody for the
back anybody yeah blue faces he's got
reached though he's a tall guy I don't
matter who it is put me in a ring
whatever the bag
has to uh he probably gets a lot of
practice dodging because he's living
with Krishan you know and I feel like
she's a shout out to her I ain't got
nothing to do with that hey
um how cool was it to do verses Man and
during a pandemic I feel like you're
you're verses was like one of the cooler
ones because it kind of represented like
an era that really hadn't been like
tapped into yet for verses
um it was lit you know what I'm saying
shout out to Bow Wow you feel me like I
used to watch him before I got into the
game growing up and stuff like that so
to you know get in the game do my thing
and then do a versus with him it was
like full circle moment you Families how
hard or how much effort did you put into
like putting the playlist together
because that was kind of the hardest
part about verses sometimes people would
they wouldn't have to order songs right
you know what I'm saying like did you
put a lot of thought in like yeah I had
to uh talk to the fans you know what I'm
saying I've sent out a couple tweets and
looked it up with the fast head it
looked you know just thought about the
tours well the best reaction from tours
you know what I'm saying just the vibe
you know it was just a whole vibe
putting putting together that show I
feel like it came out it came out nice I
got a lot of uh good comments and
feedback from that verses did you bring
out Sammy during that
Sammy did he come on do kiss me to the
phone I'm not I can't remember I brought
out French I brought French out about uh
who else I brought up I brought a couple
people out I can't remember I don't know
if Sammy was there I think he was I
can't remember I don't know for sure
yeah you and Bow Wow have definitely had
some moments together right you guys had
some the touring [__] and the verses
he's kind of like the original kid
rapper crisscross was but he's kind of
like the original kid rapper you know
yeah nah that's what's up like he
definitely you know what I'm saying was
doing his thing like as a young kid he
definitely had like all the shorties
like tweaking like when we was in school
everybody was like
tripping off about a while for so
Mother's Day Sunday what do you do for
the baby mom and then for the mom mom
man
um
just something nice like you know
whatever they want to do something
special you know what I'm saying no
surprises you're just like hey what do
you want let's go do that we surprised
him but we wouldn't do what they want to
do too you know what I'm saying do you
bring the The Gangs together like do you
have your mom kick it with the baby mom
um
because how many times you only have one
kid or do you have multiple children I
just have one yeah you just have one
yeah and you just had you just had your
one too yeah so you know it's gonna be
like everything's still new by the way
kudos to you for making it this far
without any kids until recently if if I
I would have never have guessed you only
had one kid yeah I mean see it was time
you know what I'm saying I'm I'm getting
up there now okay if I gotta leave my
legacy behind man I love it man is it do
you think having a kid changed you
yeah for sure you know you like start
kind of like you know you got to kind of
run everything through a filter now like
damn I got a kid to come home to you
that too and then just like just my
schedule you know what I'm saying
because before I could just you know
work all day do what I want now I gotta
make time for them too yeah I'm saying
so that's dope man
try to uh Soulja Boy for being a dad a
good dad at that yeah yeah
he he uh he just turned eight months he
crawling a little bit oh yeah you're
definitely you got to be changing
diapers bro you gotta get your hands
dirty bruh nah a little bit a little
something a little something like that
yeah a little something sold your car
hopefully coming soon
hey [__] Elon Musk bro Soldier Boy bruh
what we like Elon nah man no we can't
get no [__] Tesla we got to get a
soldier card right Elon Musk Elon I love
you Elon I'm playing I do too
I don't know what he's talking about I
just test drove a test we picked up the
game Big Tesla game
that's what's up man so yo go get the
album right now Soldier season go buy
some clothes so I was just season out
right now go get it buy a [__] video
game Walmart man big Draco glad to see
that the thing with you and NBA young
boy is not a real thing
yeah it's all good man just it was just
we just so happened to drop it out on
the same day a little internet exchange
which you've done millions of times all
the time you're the king you are the
internet exchange King for sure man they
know what's up man it's Draco they know
what they know what's going on there it
is my guy I appreciate you pulling up
brother yes sir fire